[music]
NARRATOR: Fentanyl was first
created in Belgium in 1960.
[music]
NARRATOR: It was designed
for use in surgery
and to treat the most
severe forms of pain.
Over time, American
pharmaceutical companies
found a profitable way to market
related opioid medications
outside hospital settings.
Since I've been on
this new pain medication
I have not missed
one day of work,
and my boss really
appreciates it.
NARRATOR: Prescription
surged, and patients
were reassured that the
risk of addiction was low.
Less than 1% of patients
taking opioids actually
become addicted.
NARRATOR: They were very wrong.
As fatal overdoses skyrocketed,
doctors made prescription
opioids harder to get.
Addicts turned to heroin,
and the crisis got worse.
Then in 2015, fentanyl
emerged on the black market
in a big way.
Potent, cheap, and readily
available on the streets
without a prescription.
In the US, overdose rates
exploded to record highs.
But here in Mexico,
fentanyl became a boon
to the underworld economy.